festal bonjour on le disait des
centaines dernière se retrouve donc cet
après midi place du trocadéro à paris et
ils sont nombreux donc autour de vous
oui exactement ça maintenant un gros
millier de manifestants s'est rassemblée
ici en soutien aux arméniens du haut
karabagh ils ont répondu à l'appel du
comité de coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france une manifestation
pour attirer l'attention sur ce conflit
dans le haut karabagh qui oppose
l'arménie à l'azerbaïdjan le haut
karabagh vous l'avez dit c'est cette
région inquiets majoritairement à
peuplée d'arméniens et qui se trouve
sous contrôle azéri sous contrôle de
l'azerbaïdjan donc depuis le 27
septembre là bas les détentions à se
sont intensifiés dans cette région
faisant de nombreuses pertes civiles ces
arméniens il se disait bien meurtri à
part la situation au cas la barre il
demande une reconnaissance diplomatique
de la région je propose d'écouter à le
coprésident du ccf
vous allez nous sommes des fils de
rescapés du génocide de 1915 et nous
sommes évidemment extrêmement surpris
pas surpris mais choqués et meurtris par
ce qui est en train se passer
actuellement au karabagh et qui apparaît
comme une sorte de continuation de
remake de répétition de ce qui s'était
passé en 1915 bien sûr toutes
proportions gardées
leur objectif c'est d'éradiquer
d'anéantir de terminer d'exterminer
c'est pour ça qu'ils se surarme depuis
depuis trente ans que leur budget
militaire équivaut année par année au
pib de l'arménie aux docks c'est pas en
guerre
c'est une tentative de meurtre de
meurtre de masse et aux demande à la
france de prendre ses responsabilités
par rapport à ça eu égard à l'amitié
entre les arméniens et la france et
l'europe
eu égard au fait que nous défendons les
mêmes valeurs
voilà pour les revendications concernant
le cortège et bien il vient tout juste
de s'élancer avec une arrivée prévue au
quai d'orsay
merci beaucoup à vous à estelle charge
pour toutes ces précisions on vous
retrouve lors de nos prochaines éditions